[Music]  in today's 8 on your side the current  supply chain issues are impacting the  supply of alcohol across our country  some states are still experiencing booze  shortages related to covet  we caught up with a rep over the phone  at ararat wine and liquor wholesale off  valley view in las vegas earlier today  he tells us prices for shipment keep  going up he says he can't keep passing  along the increased cost to his  customers because he says customers are  not happy nobody is happy the cost to  import liquor from overseas has shot up  because of price increases in  international shipping and delivering  booze to bars restaurants and other  vendors has been hampered by the  shortage of truck drivers  there are problems at nearly every step  of the alcohol beverage supply chain  some producers are even struggling to  source glass bottles and some states are  rationing their liquor supply amid these  online supply chain issues